- The only one more excited for this day
to come than me has got to be Intel.
They have been hard at
work on their ARC series
dedicated GPU's since at least 2017
when they hired Raja Koduri from AMD
who was leading up their
Radeon Graphics division.
And it's finally, freaking here.
This is their Alchemist, code name,
first generation ARC flagship, the A770.
And ooh, it comes with important safety
and regulatory information.
Neat.
Let's play, indeed.
It's a cute case badge.
Holy crap, this is it.
You gotta give them full credit.
It looks flipping sick.
Hold on, this plugs into a USB header
and this is going to handle the
RGB lighting on your graphics card.
That's right, a reference card with RGB.
What is this?
International power plugs.
Is this seriously a stand for the card?
Is that what it is, is it a sta-
Oh. Oh, I see.
Why does it come with two bases?
Wait, shut up. That's their solution?
To be able to wall mount it
or wall mount it this way,
is to have two completely separate bases
with the power switch in a different spot.
- [Andy] All the engineers
were on the graphics cards.
(exclaiming)
(laughing)
- Yeah.
They couldn't engineer a better solution
but you know what, fine.
Oh, fatal flaw, we got the top down camera
and I have no way of showing
it to the top down, wait.
A solution.
(laughing)
Now the performance
embargo hasn't lifted yet
but we can talk about all
the detailed specs and Intel
has released enough performance
information about this GPU
that we can make some
pretty educated guesses.
First the basics though,
the ARC lineup is divided
up into three, five, and
seven series products
just like you would see
on their desktop CPU's.
So this being an A770 makes it
the top performer of their top series.
It uses their DG2-512 processor,
clocked at 2.1 gigahertz.
That means it has 32 of their Xe cores
and 32 ray-tracing units.
It's equipped with eight or
16 gigabytes of video memory.
That's what makes this
the limited edition.
It has 16 gigs of memory
and that's connected via
a 256 bit bus and it's rated
to draw 225 watts of power.
Which is our first red
flag because Intel says
that this card is designed
to compete against
NVIDIA's RTX 3060 and
AMD's Radeon RX 6650 XT,
both of which draw in the
neighborhood of 160 to 170 watts.
Also, neither of which
use a 256 bit memory bus.
That means that, especially
once we dig in a little deeper,
and find the transistor
count of this card that Intel
was hoping for better
performance out of this GPU.
More along the lines of a
3070 or a 6700 class card.
Making matters more complicated for Intel,
NVIDIA has already announced
their RTX 40 Series of cards.
However, NVIDIA's pricing
is so far out to lunch
that if, at the price Intel has announced,
which is 330 dollars for
this card, they do manage
to be competitive with a 3060, 3060 Ti.
And if the overclocking head room
is anywhere near what
they've talked about,
ARC could actually end up
being pretty competitive.
I guess we should take a
closer look at the card.
Man, did they ever nail the aesthetics.
You've got a diffused RGB strip down here.
Diffused RGB lighting
around both of the fans.
Man, in real life, once
it's lit, it looks amazing.
Oh, do you have a test
bench for me right there?
Bella Mans has got a test bench for me.
Hey, thank you.
- [Bell] You're so welcome.
- All right, let's just.
Yeah, what could go wrong?
Uh, that could go wrong.
One thing to note is that,
probably because it was intended
to come out a lot sooner,
the ARC series does
not use any of the new,
funky PCI-e power connectors,
it just has a standard
eight pin plus six pin.
Oh, and that USB is right here.
Is that what that USB connector is for?
I thought I remember them
telling me that it was for RGB,
but like, you're connected via PCI-e,
couldn't you just do it that way?
Can't wait to show this to you guys.
Oh, after this message from our sponsor.
Thanks to Ifixit for
sponsoring today's video.
IFixit wants to help you skip your next
phone upgrade helping you save money.
If your battery life sucks,
put in a new battery.
If your screen is broken,
replace it using one of
IFixt's fix kits starting
at just 10.99 US.
You can repair everything
from camera lenses,
to screens, batteries and more.
And their step by step guides
are designed to help you
along the way with photos
and detailed instructions.
You can visit the link
in the video description
to find the repair kit
that's right for your phone.
Hey, there we go.
Does that look awesome, or what?
Of course, there's more
to a GPU than just looks.
Starting with, is it even
gonna fit in your case?
So we grabbed a couple of objects
that we can compare our A770 to.
Starting, of course, with our classic
short circuit banana for scale.
Eh, little something
like that. Lttstore.com.
But, also some more useful things.
For context, here is a 3080 Ti.
It's the top tier flagship level card.
Hmm, it's pretty big.
It's almost as big as a 3080 Ti.
Here's a 3060 Ti.
This is more along the lines of
the kind of founder's edition card
that you might be competing
with in terms of performance.
It's a little on the long boy side.
Here's our 6700 XT,
which is actually, okay,
higher tier card than this
and it's about the same size,
which, again, would give you some idea
of what Intel was actually targeting.
And you can see this in some
of the other specs as well.
When we compared the raw pixel rate
and texture rate, memory
bandwidth, with something
like a 3060 Ti, the A770
kind of craps all over it.
But, because Intel is kind
of new to the driver game
when it comes to high
performance dedicated GPU's,
it's speculated that aside from
any architectural oversights
there might have been
on a first gen product,
they have a lot to learn.
Especially when it comes
to optimizing for older,
especially DirectX 9 and earlier titles.
And you can't not support them
because that's part of
the beauty of PC gaming
is that you've got this
incredible back catalog
of games that you can go back and play,
even on modern hardware.
Though, sometimes does take
a little bit of hackery.
In spite of all the delays,
one reassuringly modern thing
about this card is its feature set.
Intel is claiming that
right out of the gate
they're going to have
Ray-tracing performance that is
up to 65 percent stronger,
peak, compared to their rivals.
Okay, so up to, peak.
That's a lot of qualifications, but,
hey, at least they're
gonna support ray-tracing
right outta the gate and they're
gonna have support for Xe Super Sampling.
XESS, which is a competitor to
NVIDIA's Deep Learning Super Sampling
and AMD's Fidelity
Effects Super Resolution.
Using AI to boost frame
rates at higher resolutions.
How well it works though,
remains to be seen
and based on how much work NVIDIA and AMD
have already put into this technology
I would say Intel is going
to be playing catch up.
Where they won't be playing catch up
is in their display interfaces.
On the back here, we're
going to find HDMI 2.1.
So you'll be able to do up to 4K 120 Hertz
or 8K 60 I believe, you
can anything on 2.1.
And this is where things get really cool.
This is our first hands
on with display Port 2.0.
However, unlike previous
version of display Port,
DP 2.0 is not just a cut and
dried, here's what you get.
It's divided up into ultra high bit rate,
UHBR 10, 13.5 I think, and 20.
And what those numbers mean
is the data rate times four.
So these are DP 2.0 UHBR 10
for a total of 40
gigabit per second ports.
Okay. It's a little confusing.
Kind of wish it was just UHBR 40
so that that would be a little
more intuitive for normies.
But, in a world where USB naming
conventions exist I guess this is a win.
(chuckling)
Another win, and another modern feature
is Intel Support for AV1 and coding.
And, not on this GPU, but we
have actually played around
with it a fair bit in the last week
on Intel ARC on the A380 and
it's pretty freaking cool.
At 3500 kilobit per second,
our encoded game streaming
footage looks about the same
as NVIDIA's end bank at
6,000 kilobit per second.
So what this means is that
once platforms like Twitch
support it, you can expect
to be able to stream
at the same quality that people can today,
on a much lesser internet connection
or you can expect to see
better quality Twitch streams.
Pretty cool.
For all my positivity, though.
And as much as I would love
for there to be a valid
third competitor in the
dedicated graphics card space,
I do have to temper my
enthusiasm a little bit
because Intel is up
against a lot of obstacles.
They've gotta figure out
that backwards compatibility
game performance, they've
gotta compete with
AMD and NVIDIA both releasing
new series of GPU's when
ARC Alchemist was really supposed to be
competing with the last series of GPU's.
And another big one is that we talk about
second hand GPU's a lot and
given the recent crypto crash
there's a lot of them out there
at very aggressive pricing.
And the reality of it is that
Intel doesn't have any used
GPU's and they certainly don't
benefit from selling them.
So it's going to be an
extremely competitive market.
They seem pretty confident
in their 329 pricing
and I certainly wish them luck.
But, hey, if that doesn't
work out for them,
then it can only be a win for gamers
because they've made them so now
they definitely have to sell them.
Just like I'm gonna
sell you that you should
go subscribe to LTT while
you're subscribing to
Short Circuit so you
don't miss our full review
of this and other ARC Alchemist cards.